[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández y
hoy los llevaremos a Estados Unidos
el 65% de los estadounidenses vive con
lo que gana cada mes sin lograr ahorrar
un dólar el aumento de cerca del 30% de
los precios de los alquileres en las
principales ciudades del país una
inflación récord en los últimos 40 años
y unos salarios que no se ajustan al
costo de la vida han afectado
financieramente a muchos habitantes
esta realidad ha empujado a muchos a
quedarse sin techo o tener que buscar
dos o más empleos para sobrevivir en
Estados Unidos hay más de 26 millones de
personas con varios trabajos sin contar
a los trabajadores indocumentados a este
creciente número de trabajadores se les
llamas working pool o nuevos pobres
porque aunque trabajan largas horas
viven en condiciones que se parecen a
las de la pobreza nuestro corresponsal
en Washington Cristóbal Vázquez autor de
este reportero nos acompaña Hoy les
saludo Cristóbal Cristóbal
es la nueva realidad de estas personas
que a pesar que tienen trabajo están más
cerca de la pobreza
Armenia y además parece no encontrar
soluciones a largo plazo tiene que
trabajar dos o tres trabajos madrugan en
el caso de una de las que entrevistamos
en este reportaje madrugan a las seis de
la mañana entran a su casa a las 11 de
la noche para poder solo pagar renta y
comer con lo justo tienen presupuestos
muy marcados que si alguna emergencia
pasa de salud alguna muerte o alguna
otra accidente pues quedan completamente
expuestos y obligados entonces o a
endeudarse mucho más o a tener que
buscar otros trabajos como es el caso de
muchos estadounidenses que aunque la
cifra Pues dice que es este porcentaje
muchos dicen que son muchos más Los
estadounidenses que tienen que tener dos
o tres trabajos para poder subsistir en
las ciudades pagando rentas y hasta tres
mil dólares al mes Con un apartamento de
un cuarto
ya volvemos con Cristóbal aquí la
historia
[Música]
el alto costo de la vivienda la
inflación récord y los salarios bajos se
exponen a muchos a quedarse sin techo en
las principales ciudades de Estados
Unidos en Washington más de 4.400
personas duermen en las calles de la
ciudad cada noche según la alcaldía
Esta es de Tres metros por tres metros
aproximadamente y se armen 30 segundos
Gina marcan ahorita una de estas carpas
muy cerca del departamento de estado y a
la organización paramericana de la salud
como a muchos vivir en estas condiciones
le ha pasado factura a su salud mental
usted ha considerado y era uno de los
albergues que ofrece la ciudad no no
ellos quieren que yo me quede acá porque
tengo que trabajar en mi personalidad
son estrategias de personalidad yo tengo
problemas de visión aprendí a planear en
el piso además que se supone que debo
hacer
sentarme ahí con una cantidad de gente
lo he hecho antes cuando aprendía sobre
habilidades
en Washington existen 24 albergues
temporales sin embargo las personas sin
hogar prefieren no ir allí ni siquiera
en invierno o riesgos de ser robados o
contagiarse de enfermedades Queen y
federstone estuvo 12 años sin techo
durmiendo la mayoría del tiempo en su
carro porque en los refugios donde vivió
tres años no lograba descansar en parte
por la condición mental de otros
cohabitantes
si ellos tuvieron una mala noche o no
podían dormir
o de pronto no Se tomaron su medicina
para la depresión
si de pronto tenían ataques de ira y de
llanto y empezaban a gritar y maldecir
Entonces te despertaban
y era difícil lograr que entraran en
razón
y volver a dormir
la llaman la diva de la calle porque
siempre guardó su Estilo a pesar de
haber sido desalojada de su edificio
donde vivió por décadas con su familia
allí los vecinos todavía se acuerdan de
ella
[Música]
él no sabe Pero perdí mi escucha estoy
sorda
ella ya no puede escuchar y están
haciendo un documental aquí al frente
del edificio sobre cuando ella quedó en
la calle después de vivir acá por 45
años
la renta subió y mi salario bajó a sólo
600 dólares
y no fui capaz de seguir pagando el
alquiler
por el valor de estos apartamentos en el
mercado
los dueños querían que inquilinos como
yo
que llevábamos mucho tiempo nos fuéramos
del edificio
para cobrar mucho más por el alquiler
del apartamento
creció estudió trabajó y vio morir a sus
padres en ese apartamento de Tacoma Park
al norte de Washington el agua cuesta la
luz puesta el gas cuesta la comida
cuesta
Yo sabía que necesitaba trabajar
para pagar todas las cuentas
Pero simplemente no me alcanzaba en ese
momento
fue ahí cuando me quedé en la calle
los fines de semana Queen y viaja hasta
gaithers Maryland para ir por alimentos
gratis que entrega la organización so
what Else allá también acuden personas
como Rocío una salvadoreña que va tres
veces a la semana por alimentos para
cocinarle a su hijo que trabaja en
construcción
mi cuñado me llama por teléfono me voy a
recoger en 10 minutos yo estoy lista
venimos haciamos la fila y el proceso es
igual siempre o no camina camina llega
la mesa ahí de como le dije le ponía El
puntito acá si uno quiere dar una
donación lo da y luego ahí le dicen cómo
es que uno tiene que ir agarrando las
cosas dos o tres de cada producto
es la directora de la organización
Software que reparte comida gratis
cuatro días a la semana alimentos que no
logran vender en los supermercados y los
donan a su proyecto
en realidad Estamos abiertos a que todo
tipo de personas vengan
ya sea porque no tienen comida para
poner en sus mesas
o porque tienen que trabajar mucho y
están tratando de ahorrar para otros
gastos
según Megan el número de personas que va
por comida gratis ha aumentado este año
por la inflación récord que vive el país
que para los alimentos supera el
12%. los precios de la gasolina
incrementaron mucho recientemente y los
precios de los alimentos también
subieron mucho eso ha hecho que las
filas se pongan bastante intensas
bastante largas ahora los precios de la
gasolina están mejor pero los alimentos
siguen siendo muy costosos así que vemos
gente nueva todos los días 65% de los
estadounidenses viven con lo justo para
pagar sus gastos mensuales la inflación
récord de 8,2% en los últimos 12 meses
Un aumento del 30% En el alquiler de
vivienda en las principales ciudades del
país y unos sueldos que apenas crecen
4,9% hacen que ciudadanas como cami
viola politóloga de 23 años tenga que
tener dos trabajos para poder pagar su
renta y sobrevivir en Washington
tengo un día laboral
desde las 8:30 de la mañana
hasta las cuatro y cuarto de la tarde
como 15 minutos para caminar hasta mi
otro trabajo
y después de cinco
a 11:30 de la noche
Así que es mucho más fácil solo comerse
algo en el camino como una barra de
proteína humana
cami trabaja en una organización sin
ánimo de lucro y también como barista en
un café de Washington mucho arroz en
realidad
como mucho huevo frito con arroz yo como
eso posiblemente todos los días
es lo más barato y es delicioso
pero sí mi salud definitivamente ha
empeorado desde que me mudé a Washington
Es realmente muy complicado cocinar para
mí cuando tengo que estar trabajando
todo el tiempo
es difícil no tener un vicio con Tanto
estrés que tengo todo el tiempo
siempre estoy muy ansiosa de lo que
viene de la próxima tarea pendiente del
Próximo pago
ella gana $3000 al mes en sus dos
trabajos pero gasta más de la mitad de
su sueldo En el alquiler de un
apartamento compartido además de sus
gastos en servicios transporte y
alimentación tiene que destinar 400
dólares mensuales para sus medicamentos
otro de mis grandes miedos es
despertarme cuando tenga 30 años
y seguir haciendo lo mismo
tener que trabajar duramente cada semana
solo para sobrevivir
Cami quiere hacer una maestría en teoría
política y trabajar como académica pero
por ahora tiene que destinar su tiempo
libre a trabajar como barista
si no estuviera haciendo esto podría
dedicarle mucho más tiempo y energía a
mi otro trabajo
y darle toda mi atención
podría crecer más como diseñadora
gráfica y escritora
enfocarme en los detalles de lo que hago
porque ahora apoyan muchas direcciones y
es difícil concentrarme
según la reserva Federal al menos 26
millones y medio de personas en Estados
Unidos tenían dos trabajos para el 2019
Ruth Portillo es madre cabeza de familia
y a sus 60 años también tiene dos
empleos para poder mantener su hogar y
sus hijas Uno de ellos es haciendo
limpieza en edificios de oficinas aunque
se jubile en cuatro años seguirá
trabajando para sobrevivir
mi pensión normal y pienso seguir
trabajando de la mitad del día un turno
pues
eso es lo que piensas hacer y ahí se los
planes Ruth Portillo duerme poco tiene
graves problemas de salud y pronto
tendrá que operarse para tratar de
recuperar su visión tengo una presión
altísima me salió el leucoma tanto así
me afectó el estrés y tengo la operación
pendiente y que pienso hacérmela pronto
pero tengo que organizar todo el dinero
el tiempo
doctora en economía y especialista en
temas de pobreza y desigualdad además de
Los Altos costos de alquiler el
estancamiento de los salarios y el
racismo la falta de un estado que
ofrezca servicios básicos de salud
vivienda y alimentación es un factor
clave que profundiza la pobreza
las personas no están empezando nuevos
negocios porque no tienen esa seguridad
económica que necesitan para poder tomar
el riesgo de emprender o tampoco
disponen del capital que necesitan para
empezar entonces hay costos muy altos
para la sociedad cuando no le damos a
los ciudadanos es el fundamento básico
de seguridad económica que necesitan
para dar el primer paso
de regreso con quini quien hace seis
meses logró con la ayuda del gobierno a
encontrar una vivienda subsidiada donde
puede volver a descansar todas las
noches cocinar y guardar su ropa
defendí mis derechos
para que me ayudaran a encontrar una
casa
he sido habitante de calle 12 años
y sabía que algún día tendría techo
tenía que tener paciencia
para el periódico streetzen semanario
que vende en las calles de Washington
para ajustar lo que recibe de pensión su
poesía cuenta sobre el problema que
afrontan los que tienen techo y los que
buscan uno en este sistema
las personas en realidad no pasan mucho
tiempo en sus casas
Y puede que no estén en la calle porque
tienen un techo
Pero en cuanto a tiempo en mi poema
están ellos con tiempo suficiente
para poder disfrutar lo que es tener una
casa
para muchos ni siquiera se trata de ser
rico sino dejar de ser pobres porque la
pobreza es muy costosa buscan como mis
quini asegurarte hecho y alimentación
para tener la libertad de pensar en un
futuro sin el yugo del trabajo constante
y las fuerzas del mercado
estamos de vuelta con Cristóbal Vázquez
Cristóbal Qué está haciendo el gobierno
de Cara a esta nueva realidad de los
estadounidenses
pues es muy poco lo que puede hacer el
gobierno porque parece que ya ese
vínculo entre empresa privada y gobierno
se rompe la empresa privada antes de
alguna manera se beneficiaba del
gobierno para que este tuviera una mano
de obra pues preparada para la empresa
privada pero parece que la
automatización y el hecho de que la
globalización hizo que muchos empleos en
Estados Unidos se trasladaran a otros
países donde era más barato esa mano de
obra pues hizo que la empresa privada no
necesitara más el gobierno para
esa mano de obra Por ende entonces
pues hay una tendencia a pagar menos
impuestos menos impuestos implica pues
menos menos servicios que el gobierno
puede brindarle a las comunidades por
eso en Estados Unidos entre otras cosas
Pues no hay servicio de salud Hay muy
poca asistencia para la vivienda y pues
no hay ayuda para de Educación Así que
es muy poco el margen de maniobra que
tiene el gobierno para pues eh brindar
estas necesidades básicas Gracias
Cristóbal hasta aquí reporteros de la
semana recuerde que para sintonizar esta
y las emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]